open it to you Community Pride on Las
Vegas now is sponsored by Findlay
automotive group Southwest Medical part
of Optum care Silver State Schools
Credit Union and NV Energy
Earth day is Saturday April 22nd and NV
Energy is sponsoring the Earth Day
Festival this weekend we have Craig Rose
senior project manager and DSM of
education for powership by NB energy and
from the Springs Preserve we have Nick
Tully welcome you to so great to have
you
um Craig NB energy is always involved in
this community whether it is
scholarships or going to schools and
helping kids and now you're a part of
this Festival why what what is the
message that you're trying to send to
the community by being involved in all
of these events we're all part of the of
the community right so we all have to do
our part to help save the planet and
save the Earth and so what better way
than on Earth Day to celebrate that and
envy Energy's a proud sponsor of this of
this amazing event you guys are really
fabulous Nick tell us about this the
Earth Day Festival Springs Preserve is
absolutely fabulous what do you guys
have going on there so it's all about
bringing the community together to
celebrate Earth Day at the spring
preserve and we're gonna it's for all
ages so bring your family and friends
we're going to have tons of activities a
lot of Education where you can visit
with green industry exhibitors you can
grab a bite to eat from a lot of our
food trucks we have conservation themed
craft activities there's a ton to do and
it's for an affordable price as well oh
that sounds like so much fun this
Saturday Craig while I have you here
it's summer is coming what are some ways
that we can conserve energy as we go
into the warmer months well it's so
important that we all do our part right
so
um simple ways like keep your curtains
closed when during the day right that
will that will help with your air
conditioning keep your lights off when
you're not in the room and make sure the
lights are LED that's really important
to do
um
uh run your dishwasher when it's full
know what's what you want from the
fridge before you open the fridge oh I
know I like sit there forever I yeah
that's a really good tip and what should
we always keep our thermostats at yeah
so in the summer we keep it at 78 that's
recommended to keep it at 78 and 68 in
the winter and I know sometimes that
might be tough but here challenge
yourself right if it's if it's at 75
maybe just move it up one degree for
three days if you notice see if you get
it and then try again right but 78 is
the recommended temperature well we are
so excited that you guys are sponsoring
this fantastic event Craig Nick thank
you so much if you want to check out the
Earth Day Festival it's happening this
Saturday 10 a.m to 4 P.M you can get
information at
nvenergy.com powershift or you can check
out the Springs Preserve website too
Rocky